la situation à lampe B12 ans en Italie
ou sont arrivés plus de 8500 migrants la
semaine dernière la plupart ont été
déplacées sur le continent dans des
centres d'accueil 123000 premiers qui
sont arrivés depuis le 1er janvier la
première nationalité c'est la Guinée
donc le migrant économique Côte d'Ivoire
un des pays les plus riches développés
d'Afrique de l'Ouest un nouveau bateau
des garde au quotidiennes qui a accosté
ici au port militaire à bord des hommes
des femmes et des enfants et c'est comme
cela et bien depuis maintenant plusieurs
jours et parfois ils viennent de très
très loin ils viennent du Bangladesh ils
viennent de l'Éthiopie du Soudan ce sont
quasiment exclusivement des francophones
c'est la différence d'ailleurs avec la
vague migratoires de 2015 vous aviez
beaucoup de Somaliens d'érythriens de
Syriens je sais pas où il est allé moi
j'y suis allé à l'opausa 11000 en 48
heures 11000 hommes quelques femmes
quelques femmes très peu quelques
enfants qui servent en fait d'alibi je
suis pas
obligé de la régulation donc il y a un
droit à mon pays de réguler les
migrations de dire qui eux qui on veut
pas et ensuite il y a l'intégration
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup d'enfants
il y a eu d'hommes bien sûr on tire
qu'il n'y a pas de femme ni l'enfant ça
c'est pardon madame la
député